Jo problém.
Takhle tady teda není k tomu jinému jdeme
dál, jdeme na projekt jenom pérováníc.
Tady prosím tě,
mohl bys to komentovat tu kvalitu?
Teda když tady vidím ty 4 věci,
tady z toho máš ty ultimátní věci prosím.
Kvalita je v poslední 2 týdnech.
Vzhledem k nějakým problémům,
který jsou načtenéch to bylo takhle,
jsem to jako navnímal od od Ondry tak
není úplně ideální.
Máme tady David a tak já nevím,
jestli ty David chce okomentovat kvalitu.
Svobodu.
Ze své strany.
Hele co se týká, že bude na hodinu,
tak tam jdeme nahoru.
Jako standardně se držíme někde mezi 43
44 jo tam jediný co nás hejtuje,
tak jsou prostě ty databáze.
A zároveň i část jakoby.
Já nevím,
ať už to jsou ty virtuální palety.
Prostě jsou na to založený 2 bugy,
řeší se to,
je to nějaký komplexnější problém?
To znamená ta kvalita expedice je teďka
způsobená primárně.
Já vím, že jako špatná způsobený tím,
že tam nefungovaly ty sorbiny.
To se opravoval nějak přes víkend.
To to mělo.
To mělo dopad jako na 5 % na 5
procentních bodů z toho bejt a nevím
teďka, jestli ten šestnáctej tejden.
N.
Ale minulý týden,
tak tam jsme byli někde na 92 93.
Já mám akorát problémy,
já se prostě nedostanu za živýho boha do
dayliny.
Jo a tím, že prostě.
Práci nejsem,
protože tenhle tejden mám volno,
tak jsem s tím trošku.
Ne joblajnová kvalita,
takže tam jako ten rozdíl.
Klidně davide, prosím,
jestli na na příští týden to budeš mít
připadat nějaký komentář,
tak to bude taky super.
Hele budu mít příští tejden.
Už jsem normálně v práci a teď lítám po
doktorech a podobně.
Takže jako příští tejden koloniál mít
budu a já ti jsem ty kvality hodím do
chatu.
Jo dobrý, díky.
Jo ať už to ať už to je expedice na čas
vozu,
ať už je to prostě ta produktivita za ten
17 ten nebo 16 ten tejden.
Od šestnáctej tejden mám normálně jako
lock performance, který tam by to mělo.
No ono backa bacha ono to lock
performance jako trošku občas.
Tam by to mělo lícova.
Dělá.
On neříká to pravdu, tak jo,
protože mi to prostě třeba,
co se týká jakoby ty stor,
že bude na hodinu, tak prostě musíme.
Prokliku a opravujeme to až 3 nebo těžší.
A ty jo.
Super víme, tak je reálný tyto pro.
Přesně 4 dopravy.
Tak přesně číslo toho vyprostánu
prezentace je to.
Správné číslo pohledu tady digerigo David,
že se potom zpětně nějak jako opravuje.
No já jsem koukal na ty čísla,
který jsou předtím jako lícuje to nebo
Já hele dej mi chvilku já ti to kopnu do
toho chatu já zavolám za polšovi a dám ti
nejlíp se to nějaký 100.
Jo jo a pak.
to hned.
Dobrý.
Díky.
Jo jo za málo.
Jenom 2 otázka je na ty výstupy poznatky
z cest?
Zastres testu ze stres testu.
Hele.
1 cíl byl o tom,
protože vyrovnanej výtvor.
To se povedlo za mě jako velmi dobře.
A vlastně.
Celejch těch nebo 8 hodin nebo?
Byl.
S ním se jako o 500.
Problém?
Což je jako za mě skvělý ikon,
nebo tam v zásadě nebylo to jenom v
zásadě jako žádnej technickej problém.
Co z toho, co co si z toho,
co jsme si z toho vzali,
je rozložení objemu na jednotlivých
stortrech.
Na tom by měl pracovat Michal sražím,
protože.
Od minulýho stres testu se vyprávělo o.
To se dá.
Že jsme jako extrémně dost v tom
prostředí s outer,
což se to třeba neukázalo.
I Michal dýka má za úkol i vlastně jako
ve spolupráci s Filipem vlastně na tom
dělá.
Já jsem po něm chtěl i nějaké jako
aktuální aktuální status nějaký nástroj,
který nám to jako reportovat.
Takže rozložení econu na těch soundtrack
je teďka jako hlavně důležitý, co musíme,
co musíme odpracovat?
Tak asi dobře.
Děkuju, proč teda přímo.
Agendě.
Petr.
Na projekty.
Rád si vezmu projekt a pak si probíhám
tabulýkama a jenom si je ověříme,
že teda ty milníky jsou hotový,
nebo se nám případně posouvaj?
A proč jo tak.
A ten frankční otázka tohle tématu,
který na tady parkuje rok jižní zásoby v
celé alze.
Ještě ať chvilku parkuje,
proběhla schůzka, něco tam běží.
Tak jo.
Zatím to není na reporting, jo není,
není tam žádný výstup jako velký z toho.
Dobrý, děkuju.
Tak jo, tedy jenom prosím tě.
Prosím tě, teď jsem tě.
Kdybysme se bavili.
Tak prosím, teď jsem tě neslyšela.
Každopádně,
1.
jestli jsem naplánovala schůzku,
je to tak.
Jo.
Velký.
Nebudu vykopávat, budu vykopávat.
Dneska jsem,
Výkon.
Teďka bude.
akorát se o tom bavila s Tomem a možná ho
příště přizvem, ale budu vykopávat jo.
Jo.
Jenom tady koukám pro knihovníka tady
máte.
A už měl míčky že? Jo 4 krásně.
Že jo.
Dej si to.
Jo takhle prostě prostě jenom podívej
tady byl nějaký milníky,
tak jenom jestli to odpovídá,
nebo to jsou nějaký hovady.
OK.
OK mrknu na to.
To je.
Ště k přesunu.
Tak snad ano, tak jsem to takhle promiňte.
Tady do toho umístěte se to má do pro má
smysl.
David smazat nebo opravit co?
OK.
Jo jo no to dokopy.
Tak jo,
přeskočíme se a je to asi hlásí tak tak
jo ten kluk jo nechceš dobře,
tak to je to prosím tě.
Provoz ten co je u 24 7 novinky co se
událo, co bude.
Tam se toho už moc neudálo.
Vlastně jedinej milník, kterej tam máme,
tak je konec konec dubna přesun petu
bazaru. Doplnila jsem tam aktuální stav,
teďkon, jak to vypadá, protože postup.
Stupně přesouváme a tam vlastně vidíte ta
expe d přesunu o 50% XPO small 64 a pad
při přesunuto přibližně 89%.
Nic nic jinýho k tomu jako nemám,
prostě postupně to probíhá do třicátýho 4
bude ta plocha úplně prázdná a riziko
zůstala z minulýho týdne.
Jo.
Tohle jste nějak se u toho rizika pohodlí?
Vymýšlení toho provizorního řešení,
nebo to stále spí?
Ne ne, ne dohoda taky zase s Tomem,
co jsme dneska řešili,
akorát že se zinkem řekne,
koho přizvat na tuhlectu schůzku za mě to
je zatím Honza bašek Hynek to já AA.
Říci jak dál, tak nevím,
jestli pak inka ještě někdo někdo dal
napadne a budem hledat to řešení.
Fyziku.
Řešení,
jo hledá se takhle napíšu na poznámečku.
Jo jo ano ano?
Knihovníka jenom kliknu film do
montfrozný tabulky, pardon.
Jo tady to letí.
Pádem všechno na tohle tady máme 4. 4.
já mám tady pane bubnat.
Ano.
Ne to držíme.
Jo.
Proč se na téma tak za to všechno
děkujeme tak?
Venku prosím tě, destrukce,
technologie a materiálu.
Ano tak.
Bez technologie jsem říkal poslední je
míra souhlasí s tím,
že to bude prodávat přes aukční portál.
My jsme o tom už informovali surplex,
což je ta firma,
která s tou akcí bude zabývat.
Aktuálně připomínkujeme smlouvu,
řešíme s právníkama, zda nám vadí,
že je to podle německého práva.
Zatím to vypadá,
že by nám to nemělo vadit AV podstatě
shoda,
probrali jsme to s těmi 3 nějakými
odděleními u nás nebo částmi říkáme,
že do té aukce chceme zahrnout ty extroje,
tak obilový materiál.
Tak i ten materiál,
respektive díly od inotechu.
Tam jsme trošku zabrzdění teďka na tom
inotechu, protože definuje.
Všechno materiálu chce prodat,
protože je to opravdu velký kvantům,
takže dokonce týdny mají nějaký termín,
aby dodali.
AV pondělí si to znovu čekneme,
nicméně zítra máme schůzku se surpexem.
Chceme doladit tu smlouvu,
chceme jim tam říct,
co všechno bude součástí té aukce a
chceme se nějak posunout k tomu,
abychom aukci dokázali ukončit do 31. 7.
To znamená do toho začátku jakoby
příjmový sezóny.
Toť asi vše.
Napíšu nám surlexového 23. 4.
vinotéch do konce.
Dokonce to znamená 24. 4.
Jo 24. 4.
I.
A dát ty závěje, takže já obecně.
Tak jo.
OK já jenom kliknu na teda sem jenom,
pardon,
řekl to jenom vám destrukce technologií.
Jenom se podívám tady OK nabídku resty to
probíhá teďka,
to je hotový a patnáctýho 9 obecnej
nějakej paušální, prostě nejvíc vyčistit.
Jo a tam to super tak děkuju.
Rád bych řekl výtlak na tebe,
ale výtlak mě už teďka bnucka,
tak lucko výtlete autostoru 310 000 stoj.
Tak tak.
Ano.
Tady.
Martina co se týče aplikace,
tak tam není 0 změna oproti minulému
7.
statusu.
Když přijdu přejdu na facebooku,
tam je hlavní to,
že proběhla včera referenční návštěva v
Německu.
Na bota k tomu bude mít Martin zítra
schůzku s Vaškem burgerem budou dávat
dohromady nějakej výstup.
OK.
Ale jenom lucko,
prosím tě tady k tomu k tomu k té
Pak je tam.
aplikaci.
Nasazený celkem 34 úspor.
To už se tady bliká nějaký ten další
status, tak tam jde nějaký zasek.
Tak zaseklý nebo?
Nebo.
Si říkal, že 0.
Změna nebo tak teďka tam je.
Jenom.
Hele hele co se týče tohohle máme
nasazený ty 3 na další čekáme u Pavla,
v rámci toho řídím Pavlu pavloviovou
frontu.
On tam má samozřejmě víc věcí než jenom
nás.
Čili je tam zařazení v rámci tý fronty a
čekáme na uvolnění místa,
ať můžeme doprogramovat ten zbytek.
Takže nebýt vod Pavla zhruba v termín do
kdy asi se na to podívají, nevíte ještě?
Aktuálně jako pevný termín nemáme
samozřejmě záleží na tom,
jak se budou dařit ostatní projekty se
jedná o robotican další,
jako je zvládneme v rámci pavlové fronty
uzavřít.
Jo.
Tím pádem jsou volní místo pro další
projekty.
Po týdnu je to nějaký blokátor v něčem
pro další věci v rámci projektu?
Víceméně by to žádnej blokátor by
aktuálně neměl být známý.
Pro vás?
Prosím lucko. Pokračujte.
Tak.
A říkala jsem u toho facility,
tak tam platí i to,
co jsme říkali už tady pro týdnu.
Dává se dohromady,
nebo máme těch nejčastějších závad?
Na konci dubna zhodnotíme,
kam jsme se posunuli,
to je stále se pracuje na vylepšení chyb
a včera byl Martin s Vaškem na referenční
návštěvě dnes krobota v Německu a říkala
jsem,
že zítra mají domluvenou spolu schůzku
budou dávat dohromady nějaký výstup.
OKA nějakých takových top high lifes ty
návštěvy je třeba.
Co vás inspirovalo nebo co si odnesli?
Neboť.
Hele my jsme obecně procházeli víceméně
celkových autostor.
Ten jejich autostor je víceméně značně
podobnej vzhledem k tomu našemu,
ať už se jedná o stroje jako takovýho
froopu.
Další věci, co se týče toho robota,
kvůli kterýho jsem vážně byli,
tak máme 100 informací víceméně,
co jsme potřebovali nějaký chyby to
zvládne, jaký to nezvládne,
co jsou řekněme?
Marketingový řeči o autostoru a co jako
reálně ten robot umí?
Teď to jen potřebujem pro naše chyby,
jelikož naše struktura chyby je trošku
jiná než ta jejich a zhodnotit si v rámci
nějakého celkovýho počtu ušetřeného one
timu nebo valibility toho stroje.
Jestli se nám to vyplatí, nebo ne.
Data struktura víme, že.
Je to loděj.
Oni maj poměrně čerstvý grif ten jejich
grid má zhruba zhruba rok.
Čili jim se ještě tolik neprojevují chyby
jako na,
že máme například křivý grid další,
co je tam hodně jiný je,
že voni nemaj voni,
nemaj ty dovolený biny jako my.
Nemáš vlastně tu krev tu tu stranu toho
binu tím,
jak tam občas dáváme těžké těžké skáčka a
zároveň oni nemají transsely,
kde se vám stává hodně různých chyb.
Jo čili tam ta je struktura,
chyby je o něco jiná jiná.
Naše mají zase jiné chyby, z nemáme my.
Takže tohle jsme si zaznamenali a musíme
to napárat vlastně na ten na ten náš
autostor,
abychom viděli tu finální rozhodnutí.
A jaký teda typy chyb které opravovat?
Uhelný to opravovat 2.
Jo ten normální obvod,
to je hlavní normální robot neumí nabrat.
A potřebuje za.
Zásah technika tongridu,
což znamená ať už ten bin je ohnutý,
ať už je nakřivo,
pojď tam něco přečuhuje a tak dále.
Tak se jako to je jeho hlavní výhoda,
kterou on umí u nás je to vlastně nějaká
2 nebo 3. Nejčastější chyba,
která se nám stává v rámci toho gridu.
Potom je ještě pár dalších věciček.
Co to tam dělá?
To udělá ten binescue robot is přijede
jako normální robot probin a nemůže ho
nabrat.
Pošleme tam toho robota,
který to ten víceméně on má speciální
nanda proti normálním.
Robotovi.
By neumí zvládnout.
Však normálně v aplikaci ho tam pošleš.
Nemusíš díky tomu kvůli tomu zastavovat
ještě jo.
Tak tohle jako vystřídá jo.
Jako vystřídá a udělat za něj.
Google.
Přesně tak to znamená, že nemusíš tohle.
O člověka vybral.
Že potom.
Jako ten gripper.
Hele on má úplně jinou konstrukci toho
gripru a vlastně celé té vlastně gripové
části. Oproti normálnímu roku botovi.
Jinak zbytek toho robata je stejný jako
normální robot a vlastně celý ten handler,
jakoby je úplně jiný a má úplně jiný
princip. To, jak vlastně nabírá ten bin,
díky čemuž může zvládnout ty pro nové
biny.
A eň.
Bychom především tak.
OK.
Tak jo tak je to pojem asi ty detaily si
asi ale tak jo lucko prosím pokračujte
teď.
Další bod je ta instalace,
tak tam jsem říkala minule,
že jsme zahájili stavební připravenost.
Element nám měl vyznačit minulý týden ve
čtvrtek.
Nebo budou ty prostupy nestihli to plnit
přesně dovyznačit přislíbili do vyznačení
příští pondělí.
V mezičase jsme si domluvili kapacitu u
jednotlivých dodavatelů u elektra dat
UEPS ky AU sprejů.
Měli by mít dostatečnou kapacitu.
Na to nám tam všechno zhotovit s
elementem a máme domluveno,
že nám 20 týdnech začalo zadání na
elektro a na data AV příštím týdnu by
mohlo proběhnout koordinační schůzka se
všemi těmi profesemi na místě.
A co je taková relativně veliká,
tak si to teďka řešíme.
Možnost posunu convier portu pro robobik
a že aktuálně vlastně.
To vypadá tak,
že je tam nedostatek prostoru pro robota
a budeme tam zjišťovat Filip s pilipem.
Tam nějaký další podrobnosti?
Tak je to je to taková hrozba.
My jsme se o tom bavili a zatím to jako
není riziko, protože zatím jako neříkám,
To.
že to posouváme. Zatím se jenom bavíme,
že tam je jako možnost,
že bysme to posouvat mohli,
takže zatím to.
Postupně.
Nebereme s Martinem riziko.
Jo já to možná doplním jako ten robot
víceméně může fungovat IV tý aktuální
pozici je tam jedinej problém,
že on na nějakou.
Malinko úplně na 100% vzhledem k ruka jo.
Čili s nápadem nebo jako otázkou,
zda nemůžeme posunout o 1.
Pozici ten ten konverovej port,
díky čemuž je lepší,
lepší ten poloměr otáčení pro tu ruku a
dostali by se všude na 100% jo čili
nějaký zlepšení, když tam minimální bylo.
Já budu se ****,
jak tam Filipem probírat taky zlepšení,
případně co by to pro nás znamenalo a zda
to je možný procházet vlastně takhle v
rámci těch jednotlivých jednotlivých.
Úprav v rámci toho gridu a tak dále.
Ale já si spíš jako myslím.
Tady jako ve skal c 3 stojí 40 portů,
který už tam jsou postavený a na těch 40
portů minimálně na půlku do budoucna
chceme dát robot tak.
Jsou takový a.
Říkal jsem, říkal jsem to samé,
že si nejsem jistej.
Jestli je dobrej nápad mít jako už teďka
tady víceméně jako na 2 různý struktury 1
s tím standardním postavením a vlastně
novým,
že bych to raději držel v nějaký jedný
jedný řekněme šabloně,
podle který se budeme řídit,
na kterýkono optimalizovat.
Takže taky tenhle nápad,
spíš se mi až tak nelíbí,
ale rád bych to jako možnost prošel,
případně i zjistil,
co nám to může přinést navíc.
A projděte.
OK.
Jo, pokud zjistím,
jako že tam ten přínos je veliký,
ať už jako v rychlosti robota či jako v
možnosti zaskladnění,
tak pojďme o tom uvažovat.
Pokud by ten přínos nebyl až takový,
to bych to raději držel v nějakým tom 1 v
tý jedný šabloně.
Takže když je posuneme ten port, tak.
Furt jsme jako OK.
Jsme s tím opět takhle fungujeme víceméně
do teďka.
Na co to má jakoby kabelitu nebo?
Hele jedinej dopad jak jsem říkal,
je tam v podstatě ten poloměr otáčení tý
Vyklá.
ruky,
což znamená i jak moc dobře může skládat
ty jednotlivý produkty do toho cílový
obinu, což znamená, že teďka,
když ta ruka se tam otáčí a bude to z
toho zdroje do toho cíle,
tak zvládne obsáhnout nějakou část toho
citát procent, nebo?
Pojďme slyšet a Filip třeba
bezprostřednědošáhne kvůli tomu,
že už tam nedotočí to rameno.
Vzhledem k tomu, jak tam je ten úhel jo,
ale to je o tom, že bychom zjistili,
co by navíc by nám to teoreticky to
přineslo,
kdyby se to stalo a potom můžeme hodnotit
pro a proti, samozřejmě.
OK.
OK,
takže mi to vede tady nějakej shee
řekněme a.
Jo.
Dobroš.
A.
Software.
Něco.
Tak u softwaru, vlastně tam jsme říkali,
že to zásadní bylo,
že Martin měl schůzku s autostorem
ohledně APIA byly domluveny další kroky
na automaticky stahování dat.
Tam se k tomu softwaru nic jiného nemáme.
U provozu tam se tam jak jsme minulý
minulý týden jsme říkali,
že vlastně chceme eliminovat iddletime na
příjmovejch portech byl k tomu vytvořen
reportovací nástroj pro sledování vedoucí.
To je jakoby to hlavní,
co se dělo v provozu.
A co se týče hardwaru,
tak minulý týden proběhla ta velká
týdenní kontrola. Jak jsme říkali,
že se připravuje,
dohlížel na to Lukáš kontrola proběhla,
máme z ní report a údržba pracuje na
odstranění zjištěných nedostatků.
Z těch dalších věcí pořád běží to
objednávání komponent toho hardwaru a no
a to je tak nějak asi všechno to ještě
nějakou dobu běžet bude,
až budeme mít hardware,
tak budeme řešit s provozem.
To zprovoznění 5 esky,
což už jsme tady několikrát říkali.
Ale tady k tomu reportu ta se 1 vazba
funguje, to jsou spokojení a je nutná.
Využívali ho otvírají ho.
Ale co se týče tohohle,
potom jsem teďka v aktivní komunikaci s
davivem honzíkem,
kdy s nima tohlencto řeším. Dave říkal,
že se na to mrkne s Honzou.
Budou to čekat.
Ještě myslím předávám rozdělení per směny
a takhle čili.
Hm.
Budeme se snažit směrovat s sledovat,
jak se vedou některý směny,
zda nějaká směna.
Má to lepší.
Se předává na ty ostatní směny,
je to nějaké prvotní fáze toho tahání dat?
Samozřejmě až až zprovozňuje to apíčko,
jak říká Lucka, výše,
Jo.
tak to bude moci tahat automaticky.
Takhle zatím ta vztahuju vždycky jakoby
týdenní rapoze.
Minulý týden pro ty vedoucí.
Ale a.
U toho, že dostaneš republic,
ukáže nějaké hodnoty a ty následný kroky
věděj,
co mají dělat kouknu a nebo nebo se jenom
dali.
To je máte nástroj a potom z toho nějaký
kroky si vyveďte,
nebo to je komplexní jako.
Hele co se týče,
co se týče následných kroků zaprvé v
konzoli jsme nasadili ještě report na
sledování jako aktuálního stavu,
což znamená aktuálně ten vedoucí,
může vidět, kde má jaký aidle time,
což znamená,
kdo má jaký porty stojí cílem cílo obecně
toho reportu je dostat ten.
Time nebo vlastně tu objednání číslo,
co se týče nějakých cílových kroků,
který mají z těch reportů vycházet,
tak to budu ještě s klukama dále probíhat.
Samozřejmě ten cíl je snížit ten time.
Jak to uděláme,
budeme sledovat ty extrémy budeme
zjišťovat, proč ty extrémy se staly,
ať už na kamerách či z toho s vedoucíma a
budeme se snažit ty extrémy,
kde to vlastně trvá nejdýl jako katovat
na minimum.
Jo.
Jo OK.
Asi jasně.
Prosím.
Tabulky.
Když půjdu sem,
tak jenom tady zaruluju nabídnu jak
autostor. Jenom si to čekneme rychle,
tak hele ta otázka.
Třicátýho 4 binescu uplatní to platí.
Platí.
Zpracovat.
Frankfurt.
Dokončení nové vojíčka user interface do
konce nám platí,
že jo tak teďka mám tady sedmnáctýho 4.
Provoz kontroluje hardware.
Ano.
Ch je to.
Pot není to není to dokončení UI modulu
portugalí martine.
Ano ano to to.
Ona je ono už bylo hotové jako 2 týdny
zpět,
ale nás to vždycky napadne ještě nějaký
další vylepšení to může vylepšit ještě o
další procenta bez obalo ještě
pohodlnější pro ty pro ty vedoucí,
protože já tohle to beru jako nějakou
řekněme kontinuous, řekněme.
Aktivitu.
U transforti 100.
Ale pořád je to nejpodobnější,
nejlepším a tak dále.
Sbíráme nápady ze všech možných stran.
Zjišťujeme,
co by se nám mohlo ještě dalšího hodit,
takže prostě další a další stovky na to.
To je víceméně každý,
každý měsíc se dáme to poslední den v tom
měsíci a co?
Pak vždycky dám,
jako když to nebude posunu,
ale bude to 1 z třicátýho května.
Června natáčíme.
Nechám to na vás,
jak jak to budete chtít tohle to
trackovat říkám za mě je to aktivita,
která by měla probíhat stále nejenom
během tohle projektu,
ale obecně v rámci autostoru a dalších.
V dalších případech technologií.
OK, dobrý mi se.
Poradíme to já jenom, jako je to o tom,
že?
Pro.
Ty teďka nebo Vašek teďka tady s tím bude
********* že to nemáš hotový,
ale ty už to hotový máš jenom sis
vymyslel ještě něco nového, tak.
Jo chápu.
Jo.
A dobře odbouchnu a potom půjdu bez
produktů a nebude svítit.
Jak už tady něco máš nějaký 1,
tak to není jako spíš kontraproduktivní,
dobrý, já to jako myslím, děkuju za tu.
Informaci.
To je důležitý, děkuju.
Tak potom prosím tě lucsko a provoz
zkontroluje harvýda je sedmnáctýho.
Dubna.
Co s tím?
Ano to platí, to je hotové.
Hotovo jo proč?
Referenční nástroj proběhla, tak jo zbývá.
Tady posunul hleticko výpadu autostor,
oběda hardware a tak dále. Jo,
tady zůstává dokonce dubna tyhlety 3.
Jo.
Ano to platí.
Tak.
Najednou si ještě ověřím a ptal jsem se
jmenuje.
Ptám se i tentokrát stavební práce hotovo
29. 6. jo je to mas.
Ano.
Teda 1. 9.
Že.
Super děkuji, půjdeme teda dál,
tak asi za tím všechno tak r averská
takový dvojboj zase.
Jdeme na to.
Tak.
Jo.
Asi to, když se dá už začnu jo jo.
Ale teďka co se týče obou projektů.
Máme tady hlavně i focus na tu přípravu
infrastruktury,
která jsme byli s Honzou šimáčkem ve
zlibech.
Díky tomu,
že už máme dokončené to vév go rawersku
tak?
Už jsme měli něco konkrétního,
občas to znamená za všemi čepička výrobky
má dělat.
Elektřinu bude má dělat stlačený vzduch
jak najedná tak na jak na reverse zároveň.
Už.
Jsme tam byli ohledně těch kamer,
takže teďka jsou následující kroky takové,
že?
Potřebujeme,
aby Tomáš houda a tady to doplňuje do
toho layoutu 1 pracoviště,
kde mají být například nějaké jako
specializované pozice,
které potřebují více zásuvek a tak dále.
Například pracujiště na rekultivacích,
kde rekultuj telefony a potřebují jich
nabíjet prostě 10 najednou.
Pak tam potřebují jako větší počet
zásuvek než standardní pracovní 6.
Stejně tak stlačený vzduch,
který nebudeme,
který nebudeme vlastně natahovat všude.
Nicméně jsme si potvrdili.
IS Michalem tady tomkem že.
Ty kompresory,
co jsou ve zdibech a byly teďka gotprodej.
Tak je vlastně využijem s honzovou
šimáčknem jsme se na ně včera dívali.
Michal už už jako potvrzoval,
že ještě jsou k dispozici.
Takže michale prosím, já jsem koukal,
že se dneska psali nějakou otázku,
ještě jsem tam nestihl povědět. Ano,
může se to smazat z toho od prodeje?
A my si je vezmeme pravděpodobně 1.
Beru to tak díky.
Pravděpodobně nebude jako primární druhy.
Budeme mít zpěv nějaké záloze,
abychom v případě výpadku mohli jenom
třeba přepojit.
Nechá se tam udělat teďka jenom nějaká
jako lehká revize toho stroje.
Tak jakej má být výstup toho tak.
Vlastně teďka potřebujeme od těch
jednotlivých dodavatelů vědět nějakou
jako finanční nabídku,
abychom si z tohohle toho nechali.
Nechali udělat rozpočet,
respektive já udělám ten rozpočet a mírou
si ho necháme schválit,
abychom mohli zahájit tu realizaci.
Elektrika my na tomu rozumíte,
to se budete.
Ptát jo tak.
Blbý je,
že bez té elektřiny to tam jako
neodehraje, takže věřím, že to je.
Uvnitř celé roky.
Platba co se týče hr tak už máme za sebou
prašťanek.
Konzultace se zaměstnanci s drtivou
většinou máme podepsané důvodky na změnu.
Ta výkona práce co nesouhlasili,
tak už buď byly.
Odcházet.
1 problémový pracovník, kterej se tam.
Tam to bude asi nějaká jako kličková a
zadávání.
5.
Je je to přesun,
ale vlastně někdo si to jako nechce
nechat být, takže.
Ale řeší to.
V nejhorším případě se stane to,
Pane f.
že tam toho člověka budeme muset nechat
dokonce v listopadu.
Takže pokud by tohle variantu tak
vystikou pořešíme,
co tam s tím člověčkem udělá jenom pro
něho využití?
Tak.
Jako na doplnění od týmu bazaru a simoni
Charvátová jsme dostali.
Projektů požadavek,
že by tam mohlo být spojení návodů a
odpad.
Prosím.
No a rekultivace prostě k frantické
kávovary a podobně tak,
aby s tou vodou jako nemuseli jako nanést.
10.
Aby aby tam nemusely chodit v blance s
půlku skladu,
Incykl.
tak by bylo fajn tam natáhnout s.
To ale nevím jak tam teďka jako nejblíže
voda odpad on se Šimáček,
no že až tam bude, tak se na to podívá.
Pak to, případně buď zavrhneme,
nebo přidáme do tý realizace.
Je to jako je to vtipný, ale prostě.
Počkej,
tak to jo někdo potřebuje k životu.
Ale.
Prostě tak jo OK.
Co jsou další kroky? Tak,
jak jsem zmiňoval,
potřebujeme si dokončit tu infrastrukturu.
Výsledkem a víc ten rozpočet a ideálně
jeho schválně.
Se všemi těmi sry ať už to bylo Honza
Šimáček a už martinček,
tak jsem se jako pot.
Potvrzoval.
Y ty nabídky od těch dodavatelů,
tak je to lepší.
Se opakovalo, že dostal místo,
kde k ní může být navíc pracovat. Jo,
takže jo jo.
Je to akorát de facto zpracovávat konečně.
Vybral.
Reverzní logistika jo jo,
já rovnou já rovnou přeskočím.
Tady je to jako dost podobný
infrastruktura stejně.
Vlastně bych se vám opakoval jediný,
co se tam nebude řešit,
je ten stlačený vzduch, který jede,
nepotřebuje.
Zároveň má řešení ten návrh toho zpětného
toku.
Pracuje na tom míra a už z doprav a
dokonce týdne má teďka přijít s finálním
návrhem.
Jaké video?
Ideál světného toku od 1 sedly veškerý
zpětný tok chodil do zdi,
nikoliv dochašťan.
Jo pojmenovat si jednotlivé streamy.
Vlastně my už jsme to jako párkrát
probírali s inkem s katkou.
Potřebujem,
aby tenhleten procesák jako nakreslil,
aby si to v rámci toho procesního týmu
otočil. Jestli tam vidí nějaké háčky,
viz třeba světlý tox poboček,
protože to možná bude stát jako více
peněz. Jestli to stojí dneska,
ten kamion se bude muset otočit bezpečně
a tak dále a tak dále. Takže.
Tohle si potřebovala jako potvrdit AV
případě,
že by nám měli měl zůstat nějaký jako
zpětný tok v chrášťanech.
Tak si podle toho třeba nedefinovat,
co s ním.
Jestli mi pracoviště v anebo to
přeposíláte a pak jsem přeposílal zpátky.
Já věřím, že se nic takového nestane a že?
Nashledanou.
Ale, případně řada,
jak to poslouchat s nějakým pilotem a
musíte se koukat nějakou dětský nemoci a
přesně oni tohle to dokážou dát do
Volíme.
takového jako testovacího režimu,
abychom se jako nafejkovali balíčky,
zkusili se jako poslat,
jestli se vrátí tam, kam chceme,
aby se vrátili.
Tak to bylo teda za tu dopravní část
infrastrukturu jsem zmiňoval a pak
vlastně to hlavní téma,
který tady máme pro raversku,
tak je de reque.
Třeba kuchyně řeší tón, možná,
jestli to chceš nějak víš komentovat to
nejlepší?
Co se týče toho zadání pro IT,
tak jsme si dali schůzku nějakým způsobem
prošli,
co všechno by se mělo teda dít nějakým
způsobem Honza jako potvrdil.
To že?
Žádný zásadní je tam nevidí proto maso.
Prostě těch věcí jsme schopní si nastavit
jenom prostě nějaký vlastní nastavení.
Co teď jako jediné ladíme,
tak je vlastně zadání skrze to párování
vratek na nějaký přepravní obal.
Abychom byli nějakým způsobem schopní
efektivněji to převážet mezi těmi.
Já.
Souvisí s tím i to,
že teďka ještě testujeme na skloňování na
třídírně.
Spolupracujeme tam, jsou programem.
Testujem tam,
jakým způsobem se tam chová ta distribuce.
Bylo jsem o tom dneska IS labáčkem.
Ten je o tom jako problém žádný nevidí.
To znamená,
jako určitě by se dalo využít tady ten
funkcionality a ještě to nějakým způsobem.
Destru bude.
Zároveň jsme si tento týden prošli s
Ondrou.
Vlastně celou tu debetní sepsali jsme si
tam pár bodů.
Na které myslet přitom přesunul,
to jako primárně,
jako se to týkalo toho tery,
který jak funguje na té za tu stranu jako
toho systémového nastavování,
takže klikne si to sme si tam jako bavili
s třema lidma těch pár.
Podnětu ke zlepšení, ale i třeba Tereza.
Jsou tam jako některé věci,
které poměrně jako z pomalujou ten proces
a jako jak říkám,
není to jako pro mashave,
ale to je potom jako dobré to řešit.
V rámci nějakého optimalizování toho
procesu, třeba jako věci, že?
Se něco vrací balíkáři tak?
Takto.
Nebo teď myslím jako sebe není na ně jako
není na ně naplánovaný doklad,
takže oni tam musí potom.
Pokud je tam někdo,
kdo má trošku předesati schopný to jako
manuálně nějakým způsobem zpracovávat,
pokud tam někdo vůbec přesáhl,
není tak to všechno. Potřebuje,
aby a dost jako.
Prodlužuje ten ten proces,
byl tam i nějaký jako problém,
který jsem ale pochopil,
že už je nějakým způsobem řešení.
Problém s dobropisem a že třeba,
když je nějaký doklad, který má víc a půl.
Tak ve chvíli, kdy oni přijmou 1.
Z těch několika balíků,
tak se vytvoří na všechny,
aniž byste měli otevřít fyzicky máme
opravdu všechny.
Ale jako jsou to věci,
které už teďka jsou asi špatně zkráščené
a jako není to v souvisí to s tím
přesunem jako takovým.
Takže vlastně to nebude jako takový to
jako shift?
1.
Ten ship o přesun je tam trochu a potom
se s ní pojede nejdřív,
Stav.
že pak to přesuneš.
Já to.
Prostě my jsme sami jako přeli definovat,
co je jako nezměněné,
což jsme naštěstí došli k tomu,
že takových věcí je mimo.
A potom budeme chtít řešit,
ale jako mít to už dopředu identifikované,
co je potřeba jako přemýšlet.
Takže přesunul?
To vyřešil a pak přesunul ten model.
Pro model jako no jasně jasně a.
Vlastně je to úplně stejná diskuze jako o
těch rekultivacích,
kterou jsem teďka vedl s Lukášem janečkem,
který říká,
máme příležitost jako změnit ten proces
radu lépe a záměrně.
Pokud tady máme publikace mít,
tak je můžeme dát už v krášťanech a nemá
to zastěhování nic společného.
Jediný, co tady můžeme jako změnit,
je lépe třeba připravit tu infrastrukturu.
Vy se tak tady řešíme dřez,
vodu a odpadne ho,
ale pak já tam vnímám jako tenkou hranici
mezi tím.
Pojďme se přestěhovat z bulhar bodu b
versus.
Má jako zlepšit svět,
dělá to procesně lépe.
To jsou fakt jako 2 odlišné věci.
My potřebujem, aby to stěhování dopadlo,
ať se to tam od 1. 7. funguje.
Ale zas bych to úplně jako nenafouknul.
Cena.
Protože co bude a budeme rádi,
když se vůbec jako zahodnou,
jde o to až jako to momentu tady je.
A.
Teďka nás,
jaksi jako uděláme nějaký dodržení nebo 2
Jako obecně myslím,
že většinou není dobrá strategie,
setkání?
něco měnit těsně před přesunem,
protože než to sjedeš, vyladim,
tak pak seš takhle mezi stavu a taky se
to odvíjí od kapacit IT jo. Může být rádi,
že nám třeba řeknou, že budu zítra udělat.
Ty musíš body a.
Jo tak.
Jak jinak tam teda budete to vydání happy
happy světě a ty budete mít furt někde
jako budou nějakým.
Tom seznamu že je to teda jako takhle?
Vždycky se zlepšovat.
Takže vlastně postupně se budu o za mě,
až se přesuneme a vyhodnotíme si tady
tyhle ty jako výstupy,
které se mi stát v rámci projektu.
Tak to odevzdáme jako provozu a ten by se
měl jako řešit ty jejich jako procesní
vyhlašováky. Jo za mě.
OK tak otávejte jako nikdo nevládal,
jestli mi rozumíte,
když to jako našlo konečně říkáte,
to je to oportunita.
Jestli vůbec víš?
No.
Jakože v knihovně tak pro aby to jako
nikdy nebyla a za rok jsme řešili tu
prostě tohle. Já si tady v tom lidi, však?
Bylo a předloni to bylo.
Takové nechtěli dítě.
Jo tady jo.
No IO ra.
Dostanu pro mě. Já jsem teda přerušil,
tady jenom tady asi.
Jo.
Já jsem tam potom myslel.
Já jsem tam potom měl ještě jako 2 body,
které jsem tady chtěl vlastně vyhodit do
vzduchu.
Ten 1 bod je co vlastně s tím patrem
vkrášeme? Já vlastně teďka jako nevím,
co tam má být.
Už vyřešenej a teď jako já jsem nechtěl
jako řešit jako kdo co bude,
ale spíš jak jako sem máme,
protože reklamace mají nějaký jako
dlouhodobý odpis na ten výtrh.
Co se tam stavělo na tu infrastrukturu?
A tak dále,
a pokud já tak vytvářím novej dluh jako
na zdibi,
tak bych ideálně ten chráskej dluh jako
předal tomu, kdo tam půjde.
A bude to logistika teda OK,
tak to pak doladíme.
Mě překvapil, já bych chlapi,
kdy před obkou utráte a tohle?
Jo tam ona jako není důvod jako asi něco
z tama by dát.
No a potom ještě 2 bod jsem měl.
Řeší se.
Tady nějakým způsobem agenturní
pracovníci?
Řeší to jako hr a tam nějaký jako problém
se s tím,
že tak jak dneska zaměstnáváme lidi ze
spigy a dalších jako tady těch dodávek
služeb,
tak už takhle do budoucna fungovat
nebudeme.
A máme jako ideálně fungovat přes HPP,
případně nějaké jako dražší,
mnohem dražší dodávky služeb.
A já tam jako vidím riziko že do zdi.
V Norsku prostě dneska strašně pracují
jenom agentury.
Tak jenom tohle to jako vytahuji,
aby se nám prostě nestalo, že tam jako 1.
7.
budeme mít připravenou infrastrukturu a
budeme tam jako na sebe koukat.
Bez mám z toho upřímně jako strach podle
toho.
To se řeší Ondra a je to jako velmi
čerstvé a dneska.
Ne jako myslím.
Tábor těch lidí.
Ano.
Jo.
Jako ten switch, o kterým mluvíš,
tak je z dodávek služeb agentury.
Ale myslím si,
že pro nás by to jako neměl být dopad v
tom,
že jako nebudeme mít lidi jenom jako budu
stát víc.
Je to jan dražší.
Jo.
No tak v tom případě asi asi jako dobrý,
no protože nebylo v plánu přesouvat žádné
lidi jako srážka, že jo,
co se týče logistiky,
maximálně nějaké jako vedoucí.
A mělo se to tam nalepit jako novými
lidmi ze služeb, respektive agentur,
tak proto jsem jsou tohle to jako
pozastavovaný.
A když tondrow ty nemusíš aktivně.
Hele.
Já to s ním aktivně neřeším.
Na tenhle problém mě dneska,
upozornil luchaš Janeček.
A já jsem si to dal jako.
Do kontextu s raverskou.
Protože vím, že obecně.
Máme respektované, měla lokalitě.
Jako bodů 1 z burtaly.
Dobře.
Objev.
To je podle mě jenom jako o tom,
že někdo ti v rámci toho projektu má
zajistit lidi, jo.
A ten někde to Ondra nebo hasil?
Tak se jich test tam má nějakej trable jo,
protože způsob, jakým bude platit Ondra.
Jak s nima bude komunikovat,
to je podle mě jako na něm.
Jo, to je jako.
Kde ten jako přerod bude v.
Rámci.
Celého rámce svý firmy.
Myslím si,
že dneska bude nejmenší problém,
ale chtěl jsem to jako.
Za mě takhle vše kou víme,
že ty šaty na ty milníky tak ty hele to
BDC tady bylo 17. 4. hele měli by pak mít.
Já jsem koukal,
že tady máš jich nějak moc červených,
teda ale maminku taky no a tak pojďme to
dohromady.
Ale posílal jsem tím minulý týden.
To jsem tady nebyl,
tak jsem ti posílal ve snu tady the filmu.
Já si to snad i aktualizoval.
Za mě platné a mám je taky v ty asaně.
Dobře,
tak jenom tady ber q masnet IQ ukrajím.
Já jsem tady 17. 4. to byl minulý týden,
teda vlastně jako jo.
Máme tady 3.
Já se teda něco změnilo.
Tak máme tady pořád sedmnáctýho 4.
To už je to ještě jako není hotový.
Jo no.
Takže potřebuji tebe nový ten internet?
Takže už to je červenej asi tohle nebo?
Tak vám na to mám koukat.
Ta duše osobní 1 už byl třeba minulý,
takže teďka co vy dvaadvacátého tak tak
co?
Řekneme si, co reálný no?
Já tento týden čekám víceméně,
já to teda ani mám.
Jako sepsané akorát.
Že ten míč čeká měsíc až do konce měsíce.
Čeká.
Z toho důvodu nebo jak to?
Já to.
Můžeme mít dokonce tohoto týdne akorát.
A trošku, když tam bude příští týden,
tak budu radši jako zároveň vím,
že jako čím dřív to jako bude dobrý, no.
Jo to bylo levný.
Mezi 2.
Ne tak 1 jsem si chtěl stihnout.
Ujasnit, pracujeme v tý hympo.
To jenom před kobaj si s ním zahrádkou.
Pondělí nebo ve čtvrtek přijdeš s tím,
že tady máš nějaký písni? Jo,
kdybys to chtěl vytáhnout to talent,
s tím počítám abych.
Tedy, prosím tě.
Zítra termín mix čechoreálně nebo do do,
kdy nepotřebuješ nějaký termín,
tak tím pádem.
OK,
tak tam tedy konec měsíc je to už tam
bude pondělí, nebo?
Čtete tak do.
Ale říkám,
já teď jsem tento týden jsem stál na tom
1.
cestování, na kterém.
Teda výsledek.
V pohodě, v pohodě, pojďme dále,
ale to pak přidá to 4 jo tak připravený
nahle nastavení nových tras zpět na to
redeniverin blablabla dvaadvacátého
dneska je teď.
Máte to hotový do konce týdne?
3:24 jo.
Tak, já to tady posouvám takhle jo.
Tak.
A prosimtě už jako posvěcený katkou
katkou jo.
Dobře.
Tak.
Takže to posun tady mělo být 14 dní.
0 no tak to do konce na to byl.
Původně no tak míra už to máte,
dala by ta Katka prošla nebo tak?
Aby.
Míra to dokončuje a netroufne si ještě
jako říct.
Takhle je to za mě správně a takhle to
bude.
To si ještě projít?
A je to rád.
Ale jako.
Ty řekneš, mám na.
Tak jo proto tak jako já to zase beru tak,
že jsme to zadávali fakt jako před týdnem
zpátky nebo pomalu měsíc zpátky a pořád
to nejde,
tak pokud cejdim na tom teďka měsíc jsme
pracovali, tak to teďka budu muset.
Protože v.
Potřebuješ to mě, jde o to, že.
Jako z toho.
Jejich návrhu taky může vzejít.
Potřebujeme teda jako IT úpravy a nebo to,
že prostě to budeme svážet spolu člověk
do zdi,
tak to bude stávat 30 milionů navíc.
A co teď? A pak jako nebudeme.
Pokud potřebujeme být nějaký prostor na.
Aspoň na to to mědí tak tak dobrý.
Nechám tady pátek, jo.
Já už jsem tohle řešil IS Markétou
satošou, ať se to jako popisuje.
To samé platí, prosím tě,
tady i pro tu ermašku jak je to?
Stejný ty 1 balíček.
Jo.
To je stejný, to máme jenom duplikovaný,
to je v pohodě.
Jo takže posunu a tady teda nic na
struktura tady je ale dokonce dubna,
že tam nějakým způsobem chcete vidět co?
A jak mám tady do konce dubna,
ale upřímně.
Nejsem.
Si teď jistej jestli by rychle dostanem
od těch dodavatelů tý nabídky,
protože zatím bych to.
Nechal otevřeně.
Jsou podklady pro nasedění Tomáš, to víme.
Podklady pro nacenění.
Od dodavatelů.
Říkal, že jsi dělal.
No jo, možná spíš jako.
Pojďme.
To upravit akorát.
Píšou právě infrastruktura, řekněme.
Je připraven rozpočet, připraven rozpočet.
Jestli to tady přerušovalo SM.
Tak to vypadá spočet jo.
Schválení dobroš,
to je za mě finálový discrip.
Jo.
Dobroš.
Takhle můžeme asi uzavřít, pojďme dál.
Martinho máme že jo.
Já jsem tam ikonku marti.
Naším tady.
Super i dneska chceme pozitivní zprávy jo.
Jako 1 téma prosím.
S tedy.
Počkej jakože ty chceš,
že má být kouzelník.
A tak dobré, tak zkusím pozitivně.
Potvrzení prosím já jo.
Tak právě skočím facility abysme byli
teda pozitivní.
No počkej, tak se k nim vrátíme. Jo dobře.
Ne, ne, ne smlouva start,
ale se na ní pracuje.
Zase.
Antonii dával včera update,
že jsou tam odvorané nějaké 2 tri bodíky,
které.
Ještě si vlastně zájem, co otáčíme.
Každopádně my potřebujeme tu smlouvu,
čím dřív podepsat,
protože nám na tom visej 2 důležité akce
1 je nahlášení na živnostenský úrad jako
nová provozovna a 2 je pro nahlášení na
úřady kvůli vlastně organizační struktuře
a kvůli lidem.
Anton to ví a dělá, co je v jeho silách.
Abysme to dostali každopádně na.
Jo.
Do budovy stále plánujeme,
že se dostaneme k prvému 5.
Já mám s antonom zejtra schůzku o tom,
abysme si řekli.
A 4 5 že bysme si udělali předávací
protokol, kdo by tam přišel a tak dále?
Takže to je negativná zpráva z Plzně?
Zvíšák je v podstatě takový jako
pozitivnější odpor.
Hospodář to máme zařízeno.
A od 1 5 máme klasické vozy na plast
papír AA na XL odpad máme zajištěnu
potvrzenou dopravy.
2 ten 2. Kolo tendru je v běhu.
Mám info od Lukáše smetany,
že do konce týdne bude vyhlášení,
že bude ukončeno.
A smlouvy a tak dále máme 12 tras dopravy
stanovuju harmonogram.
Kdy to pojede s chrášem, kdy to pojede za?
Z třídírny,
kdy to dorazí do zdip a tak dále a kdy se
budu vracet prostě vratky a tam je trošku
problém,
protože příjezdy ZAB tras jsou vrozen a
od 10 do 14 hodin a my plánujeme
otevřenou od.
S 1 hodiny približně večer.
Takže tohle řešíme jak s dopravami,
tak s Ondrou máme tenhle bod na diskuzi
na na zítřejší meeting.
Upravovali jsme trošku rampub,
protože mě i formovali dopravy,
že to nebude tak jednoduché.
Abysme to ještě víc rozmělnili,
jako požadoval Vasil.
Takže v této chvíli 18 5 chceme spustit 6.
Sraz od 1 6 chceme spustit.
Tím kompletně překlopené na Plzeň a pak
bysme dopresovali XL.
Od.
Kdy?
Od osmýho 6.
IT.
Prosím tě jenom k těm tam 2 gól ten drův
běhu, ty Tomáš všechno v 1 XLA brou 1.
Ještě 1.
Dopravce na všechny 3 streamy.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne běží,
to jsou tri tendry jo,
Dobrý, dobrý, dobrý.
Dobrý den.
to jsou tri tendry a na AP máš budou
trávy herci například jo.
Drž kolek klid.
Jo super díky.
AIT internet odklad komu máme potvrzený,
čekáme na maricom na cenovku za
rozhodněný infrastruktury plus na cenění
kamerového systému.
Včera jsem mluvila s Martinem Čechem,
tak údajně dokonce tohoto týdne by nám to
měli doručit.
A organizačná struktura začala bez many.
Čekáme vlastně na na dopravy,
aby jsme mohli navázat autobus workfal
work forcelán a stanovit se jmenovala.
Tolik asi za depo pozem v této chvíli.
1. 5. nás mají pustit do budovy,
to je příští pátek 1. 5.
No prosím.
tam asi nepůjdem čtvrtýho 5 od čtvrtýho 5
osmnáctýho si prosím do hodnota tak
Přesně tak.
budete jenom plakávy.
18, protože máme jako 2 týdny,
kdy se tam můžem něco dělat a tady ty 2
Ano.
týdny vy máte teďka nějak rozplánovaný,
kdy tam jako budete lepit lokace budete
testovat, připojení budete malovat zóny,
řešit se kvůli tomu a tak dále. Jo,
na místě on se kontejnery a tak podobně
to máte rozplánovaný.
Proto tam na.
Místě bude dělat instalace ASRO.
Taky.
My máme domluveno 4 5 že tam chceme jít.
Abysme tohle doladili.
Takhle.
1.
Jo.
Tak ne všechno.
Dobrý práci na to přečet tady je pane 14
dní blonkovej k tomu abysme se abysme to
připravili tak jenom ať to jako využijem
a nezačnem to dělat osmnáctýho 5 ráno.
To je jasný, ale my ne ne ne,
ne ne my 4 5 plán je takovej,
že když nám přidají klíče,
tak mi tam Vasil Vítek a naběhnem
kontrolujeme silewt jestli sedí s tím,
co máme,
abysme si doupravili tady ty věci,
abysme si řekli,
kde budou prostě fakt ta kontagary na
odpad a takovýdle věci jo,
proto tam jdeme a pak bysme tam jakoby
vasobit ta mu zajel s někým.
Ze zdi a aby to tam dodělali jo.
Jo.
A 18 5 už má být všechno připraveno? Jo,
ne, že tam budeme něco lepit ještě.
To je super.
Žádné překvapení.
Nečekáme žádné překvapení,
překvapení vždycky přijde SV alze vašku.
Dobře ok?
A to bude i na já.
A znamená to teda,
že ten Martin čech by to měl doinstalovat
tady v tom termínu 4 až 15.
Martin čech má thatline doinstalovat to
do 8 5.
OK jo,
děkuju tak potom až budou ty milničky,
prosím tě květen,
tak tam napíšeš mikrosnoho 5 IT hotovo
Ano prosím ano prosím ano prosím nevím
jestli na jestli jestli to je nějaká
úžasný.
Super super.
garance toho,
že to opravdu bude jo ale můžu to tam dát.
No tak se to potřebuje. No tak.
Ať udělá maximum,
tedy nic víc asi říct nemůžu.
Tomáš.
Dejte 2.
Tak systémové pokrytí třídící, kde téma.
A tady jsem si všiml,
že to je s oatrysk se to změnilo, že jo.
Já jsem to dala do et risk,
protože to ta infrastruktura v hosíně
pořád není.
Takže se to prostě jako znova jakoby
posunuje.
OK.
Martin czech mi řekl,
že mi dneska dneska nejpozději zprávu,
jestli to tam maricom připojil, nebo ne.
Jsou 3 hodiny a odpověď nemám, takže.
Jo.
Takže špatný no?
Tak jo, takže to vlastně mělo být,
že jo 15:16?
Minule jsme se potkali tak 22:23 a dejte
se teda za týden. Aha, dobře.
Já jsem tam dala,
že jsme to naplánovali na retest na
Tak a pak.
příští týden.
Ano.
S tím,
že vlastně potřebujeme nějaké 2 3 dni.
Dopraváci a naše logistický procesáci
abysme to dopřipravili,
takže prostě Martin člověk to musí dneska
zítra potvrdit,
že ta čtečka se tam opravdu připojí.
Jinak to prostě nemá cenu,
aby si to posouvat.
Jinak to nemá smysl.
Jo, co by znamenalo, kdyby to bylo nějak,
je to tady tady trošku, jak se říká.
Zničený nebo takhle se to nestihlo,
tak se to cej zase posouvá nebo nebo je
Ano přesně tak,
pak pak se to prostě znova posune jo.
to.
Už jako kritic.
A to už je.
AA to už je blbý,
protože do toho denový budov,
Moc to je blbý už tohle.
protože do toho jde Plzeň.
Jo a už jakoby se nám ty lidské zdroje na
tady to, aby se to všechno zařídilo,
prostě potkávají strašně moc.
Nemůžeme ten big otestovat příští tejden?
A prohodím ty termíny hostin a big joh.
No např.
Nemáme trasy a nemáme to vůbec připraveno.
To vám zabere, jako že víš,
co vybereš trasy nastavěla lokace,
než se všechno připraví.
Nevěřím, že by to kluci stihli.
Hele a tady ty marti máte třicátýho 4 ten
je bez plán nebo si a pak hned na to v
záběhu šestýho vlastně ten bydžov,
to je úplně nějakej týden.
Ano.
Ano ano to.
To je úplně v pohodě, jo?
V pohodě, protože mi dokonce nevytvoříme,
jakoby trasy si odsouhlasíme s dopravami
dopravy.
To příští týden nastavěj na to nastavěj
kluci,
systémový systémáci nastavěj lokace
nastavěj vlastně jakoby.
To,
co potřebujeme za logistickej strany a
pak můžeme jít testovat. Jo,
pak se to zapne a pak to jde.
Jenomže ta prvotní příprava jakoby ta
systémová nám zabere více času,
když už ten hosín už maj připravenej.
Jakoby znova spustěj ty trasy.
Test.
Jo.
Testoval v bydjově a ve vratimovi do
připojení.
A bidově ho testoval Ondra a máme
potvrzený,
že tam ten signál je ale kolísá.
Takže já jsem to předala Martinovi
Čechovi, že tam potřebuje doplnit AP.
Je to Ondra změřil jak že kolísá signál.
Máš tam TC tiskárnu,
takže se prošel po tý hale na různé místa
a viděl, jak mu ten signál klesá.
To jako měřil mezi načtením tiskárny a
vytištěným.
Ano.
A ne načteným tiskového tiskoven štítku
jenom naskakování kódu a jak ti odpovídá
člečka?
My netiskneme žádné štítky.
Čtečky OK.
Takže signál tam je, jenom je prostě.
Policajt stačí například a patimou.
Od it potvrzeno,
že infrastruktura je vysílám tam chudobu,
aby tam zajel a ověřil to.
Předko, že to tam se připojí.
Předpokládám totiž, že tam.
Nebylo by lepší, kdyby se nebylo,
by lepší, kdyby se Ondra,
až tam bude na tom připravený jo
připravenej tak,
aby byl někde na telefonu s luďkovaňovou
a tam mu na dálku měřila.
Jaký tam je?
Dáte mi asi ten signál je opravdu v
pohodě.
Když už tam bude.
Můžeme to zařídit s nima ještě určitě.
Jo,
jako to máme podsvěcený tady jako z tý.
Strany.
Pořád to uděláte ještě?
Pak ti můžeme něco já nebo Hynek udělat
pro toho tady, aby to čech dodal.
A už už já myslím,
že už nemůžeme pro to dělat víc už ona
haňa je Ondra a dan než myslím,
že míra dal jasnou zprávu taky.
Takže jako já si myslím,
že víc jako nemůžeme udělat maximálně,
že bysme se tam šli připojit sami.
Tak asi jo no.
Já to bohužel neumím připojit,
ale kdybych to uměla, tak to udělám.
Jo jo.
No které jsme včera viděl tady,
když jsi byl vedle mě, kdybych to viděl,
Ne ne, ne, my jsme.
Včera měli spolu schůzku goly pad g
tak.
Já vím.
privátnej sítí a my jsme rovnou po něm s
ním seděli IS ludkou a tohle myslí,
byl Martin. Takže já mám svědka Lucku,
že tam,
že tohle jsme si odsouhlasili s Martinem.
Já už fakt nevím,
co pro to můžu udělat víc.
Dobře tak jo pojď.
K tomu vratimovu,
tam jsem se domlouval s Petrem čechákem
Ale.
martino buď příští nebo přes příští týden
tam pojedu.
Tak mi kluci na instrukce a jak to s tou
čtečkou otestovat?
OK.
Tak máme další jo.
Tak jo my se spojíme Michaela spolu
domluvíme se.
Tak Martin.
Jo, tak já ti prosím tě,
já zkusím do těch milníků jsem jo a jsou
tady nějaký červený, který.
Ta budova to je podpis.
Smlouvy tam bylo nějakého 17. 4.
zača se psali,
tak to už asi teda pasé tak jak to vidí
ten termínovej posun co?
Byly tam konec měsíce,
ale to je fakt jako nejzačí možný termín
no.
OK.
No a jak by jsme si měli?
Jako potvrdil o tom,
že když se to nepodepíšu do konce měsíce,
což je možný, takže.
Nás tam na nějaký jako předávač pustí
teda.
To ano,
ale to nám je to nám jako v podstatě jako
jako ty lidi.
Jo nějak tam pustil, nemůžeme řešit,
nemůžeme příbrady.
A ano přesně tak,
a pak bysme tam měli ty lidi načerno, jo,
když to neohlásíme.
Kategorizace práce.
Toto je jenom ohlášení nový nový nový
provozovny.
Jo.
Dobře.
No to potřebujeme. No OK.
Jana trváti třicátýho dubna.
Takzvaná obsazení v pořádku tady.
No.
Jo necháme, takhle je všechno dobře.
Dubna.
Ano.
Já.
No pojď.
Tak to děkuju, děkuju.
Dali matrix do konce dubna jenom rychle,
tak prosím tě hezká podklady pro
Slovensko obecně téma Slovensko bylo tady
do sedmnáctýho dubna, to už je pasé.
Tak co dál? Nový termín?
Matrix.
Nastavení těch tras.
Jo.
V tom.
E.
A to jste se ti odvíjí asi od spuštění
těch jednotlivých deb ne?
No, ale tohle já jsem nedávala petr.
Myslím to gérování nových tras.
Jak tě to od jednotlivejch odpuštění
jednot?
Ano.
To, co tam bylo, co jsem.
Já ti napíšu jo a popřemejšlej tak teď
nemusíme to.
Jo.
A on to vytvořil Vašek,
tady ten milník tak já nevím.
Potom.
No to si vytvořil ty.
Ale na základě.
Do a sami hlavní výstup projektu.
Tak lasques.
Jo.
Počkej počkej počkej, počkej počkej,
ale já jsem tady táhnul už od toho března
a.
Vlastně já jsem.
Že je to blbě, tak teďka se dozvídám,
že to je blbě, tak já vás jako.
5.
Tam i tam na tom vašku je tam datum do
30-06.
Občas.
Jo já tu koukám do asany tak si to tam
jenom prosím prepiš tady ano ukončeně
6.
OK.
projektu, tak si to jenom propiš.
Tady jsme to měli blbě.
Dobrý tak.
Proto.
Protože ono to je prostě jako tohle to
téma je vázaný na to,
jak se spouští jednotlivý debata,
tak se budou přetrasovávat.
Tohle tomu rozumím,
ale já jsem z toho tady dobrý. Hele,
když děláte 6 jo já jako jsem tady.
Každý prostor.
Vlastně často, co jsme se bavili v pohodě?
Slovensko bylo tady 17. 4.
jsem evidoval Slovensko.
Podklady.
Ale ještě počkej.
Camburnows, Filip.
Technicky připravený to není úplně
technicky připraveno,
nebo asi je ta stará budova ale hledá
nový? Ne,
to je máme dát jako novej milník pro ten
gen.
Že mámin novou vodou.
Tak mi na budovu nemáme.
Asi nemáme, ale chceme jít ne lesní,
nenapustíme.
No v podstatě můžem to pustit.
A ono to neměli prostorováni.
No my máme náhradní variantu,
takže já čekám od doprav.
Že řeknou, co s tím,
jestli jako hledají další 2 3 měsíce
budovu?
Tak já počítám s tím, že jim řeknu,
že to pustíme tou náhradnou variantou,
kterou vymyslel Vítek.
Protože jestli dopravy řeknou.
Že gem není schopen najít budovu to je
bod číslo 1,
že si vymejšlí že je to drahé.
To je bod číslo 2 a řeknou,
že chceš hledat.
Že budeme hledat budovu novou my.
Tak za mě to je prostě jako otevření
dalšího projektu typu depo Plzeň.
6.
Takže jako.
Máme jako dost témat dobrama.
Jan tady váznou.
No a budou váznout, protože dopravy nemaj.
Jo a že máme že jo test k ipa tady máme
gem na gen vlastně na na to nový g na to
nový diapo game čeká i Tomáš stereožic.
Cho.
Promiň.
No.
Hele OK, tady pojďme.
V.
Tom 1 systémový svoz na demo.
Jo to už dáme.
To ne teď na to Slovensko bylo
sedmnáctýho. Dubna partical už je bold.
Jen.
Povedlo se vám tam, abyste se bavili,
že řešíte ten perimetr?
Kam můžeme s directama.
Ano.
A kde už musíme jet tím?
Lennoholem.
Ano.
Tohle my jsme udělali s Filipem košem
jsme dali návrh doprava.
Taky.
A Martin Ondrášek to má dneska zvedat na
VBR ku doprav, aby si řekli,
jestli ta strategie,
kterou navrhujeme s Filipem,
je pre rok 26 za dopravy OK aleboni.
Je.
A já výstup nemám.
Nějaký jako simulace a to jako jak to
bude vycházet.
Dělá na to Martin Ondrášek a posílal to
ardimu, aby to udělal.
Můžeš mi potom prosím jenom poslat ten
výstup z toho?
Jo jestli ke to dostanu?
Jaroslav.
Jako jestli to jestli to jestli to
vychází stejně nebo líp,
tak máme ty jako depa rovnou zavřít a jít
tady.
Tu variantou?
Jo jo jo.
Až to budu mít v ruce,
tak ti to pošlu Alena dopravách maj
strašně jako jako podstav a todle se
strašně táhne.
Takže.
Hračku to mají.
A Martina o tom dneska mluvil,
ale to můžu potvrdit.
Řešil přes sundepass košík s demokraciach
30 km západního Košic.
To to tam řešilo ohledně Slovenska.
Přesně tak to je ono.
Jako komplexně jako kompletní kompletní
strategii na ty na tom Slovensku.
Michal Michal.
Vzhledem k tomu takový,
že tam nebyly lidi ty directy.
Gates in the directy máme se tam trošku
promění ta koncepce.
Potřebujeme vědět,
jestli jako tady do 1/2 Slovenska budeme
jezdit na holem nebo nebo direktem a
jestli máme jako 1/2,
jde zavřít a Košice přesunout demokracie.
Varianty asi no.
No to Martin.
A my jich máme to.
Kuřelem.
Ano to Martin.
Což mám jakoby varianty,
co je tohleta strategie od nás byla
vypracována,
my tam potřebujeme od arbio doplnit
cenovky AV podstatě od Markéty říct
zamávat hlavou. Ano,
tohle je ta strategie pre 20,
26 a udělejte prostě systémové demokracie.
Jo.
A.
Víc jako dopravy nejsou schopné zvládnout.
Takže jako.
A ti pošli mi prosím jenom ty varianty.
Jo pošlu.
Není problém.
Tak.
Zase v diskuzioná,
tím jsem zase trošku nastudoval 17. 4.
se dá to tak?
Výhled.
Nějaký výhled, co dál? Dobrý.
Koukám do pole.
V.
Půlka května.
Napíšu 15 pátýho tak nějak jo?
Dobře výběr drive for nový bidjov toto
včera byl dead live tak co je to hotový
nebo?
Toto pardon.
O jéje to je hotový, to máme hotový.
Super tak já jsem dal.
Zeleně no krása,
tak aspoň se něco podařilo.
Tak.
Tady je asi dobrý.
Dobrý večer.
Mělo by.
Milíkovi.
Vyspokojení historka dobrý den tak.
No nejsme,
protože ty strategie od dopravu chybějí,
Já nevím.
no je to špatný.
Jo.
Helena bohužel tady má dobývat.
Když tady.
Jedí jak se to je? Jo jo.
Vaše kolo pak.
Dobrý marku, děkujeme teda manipulačka,
ještě to nějaký teďka předvedl, že jo.
Ještě můžu poprosit už o tebe,
my ji tady ještě nemáme, viď míru Poláka,
který se musíme nazvat.
Toho jsem nepořád tak ještě lučku.
Poprosím tebe ram, jestli ještě tam nějak.
Hele já jsem tam žádnej status nepsala,
protože žádný update nemám. Co vím,
tak se stále řeší schválení toho projektu.
Míra mě vlastně kevary vrátil ve čtvrtek
s tím,
že se mu nelíbí nákup 3 v že za něj to
jako není potřeba,
že minimálně 1 z těch tří,
co co chce užit, se koupit,
tak eště jakoby rok 2 mohli by mohli.
Fungovat a řešilo se tam.
Vlastně.
Řešilo se tam, že vlastně.
Z toho 1 stropu,
to je potřeba vyměnit třeba.
Takhle v 1 tom stromě je potřeba měnit
převodovku, takže z toho,
kterej vlastně bysme zrušili nebo
vyřadili tak?
Vlastně teď míra má za úkol zjistit,
jestli by se z něj nedalo.
Přehodit ta převodovka do toho do toho
novějšího,
aby mohl ještě jezdit a eventuálně to
vypadá, že nákup schválenej bude 1,
maximálně 2.
Ty kusy VS tím dalšíma položkama míra
problém neměl,
ale potřebujem to schválit jako balíček.
Abysme mohli vykopávat jediný,
co tak dneska jsem se s Luckou domlouvala
na to,
Jo.
aby vykopla aspoň těch 20 paleťáků pro
Plzeň, aby se stihlo tohle,
protože ten projekt je schválenej,
takže tohleto tohleto vykopnu co nejdřív.
Ale už to tak prosím tě bylo to teda,
že jo desátýho pak na 17 brně dovolenou a
teďka co dál?
Teďka teda ta ambice to nechat
proschválit.
Tam dej taky konec měsíce.
Dobře.
Budeme to držet palce,
že to schválí na je.
Pořád do toho teďka to táhne, já už malá.
Hele já jsem se s tím dneska snažila
komunikovat.
Jako nedostala jsem od ní žádnou odpověď,
tak jo, ptala jsem se ho,
jestli potřebuje ode mě nějakou pomoc,
nebo jako jak jak to ještě teď bude,
takže zjišťuji.
Ale připravila jsem ty dokumenty pro ten
tendr, to jsem tam psala,
Jo já bych u sebe.
že tam je všechno,
že tam je to všechno připravený jenom,
ať si tam,
když tak změní počet těch VN áček,
Zač.
aby když to nebudou 3 a budou třeba 2 2.
AA mírovy opátovy jsem dávala vědět,
že se nám zpožďuje nebo zkomplikovalo to
schválení,
takže že to bude určitě deal dodaný a že
asi je pravděpodobný,
že nedostane všechny 3. Takže jako psal,
že děkuje, že.
Takže.
Jako bere informaci.
Očka vlastně dvacátýho 9 pózu míru maláka.
A.
To prezentovat on tak vlastně máte nějaký
jenom ty 1,
kdyby třeba byl nervózní nebo něco,
tak máte ještě tejden si to jako vyplnit
a 29 by teda ten projekt prezentoval víra
malá.
Dobře.
Sejmeme jo.
Děláte už to dobře?
Tak to asi taky.
Teda příjem sakra na navýšení kapacity
příjmů, tak.
Ano.
A promítám.
Tak tam z těch zásadních věcí o víkendu
byly zbourány x regály,
takže vlastně teďka ladíme s Lukášem.
Tam jsou přípravu na přesun těch batoh
stanic.
Je tam potřeba dotáhnout infrastruktura.
Dobře.
A takže tam tam to ladíme spolu?
On tam dává dohromady nějaké náklady,
které pak budeme potřebovat si schválit.
Co se týče hardwaru,
tak tam se protáhlo dodání od inteku toho
skeneru už ho.
Neměli ho teďka nějakou dobu k dispozici?
Odeslali nám ho dnes,
zítra by měl dorazit dorazit naho,
takže já bych ho v pátek dovezla.
A dovezla do chráště a mohli bysme to
začít testovat.
Takže tam tam to taky do konce měsíce.
Myslím,
že by jsme to mohli bejt schopný
otestovat a říct si,
jestli u jestli to je ta cesta nebo ne.
Co se týče layoutu tak chrašťany mžice
jsou dokončený zdi jsou v procesu tam
vlastně zatím vodvítka nemám žádnej
update jak to vypadá. Psal mi,
že se k tomu dostane možná ještě tento
týden, spíš až ten další.
4.
A víte jak je teďka o? Myslím si,
že bude dokonce do tohodle tejdne.
Jo tak proto říkám, že si myslím,
že se k tomu dostaneš ten další týden a
OK takže.
že tam dojde k dalšímu posunu,
ale nemělo by nás to v ničem blokovat.
IT pracoviště tam 0.
Změna není a vlastně ty další kroky je
dokončit to testování,
připravit se na ty přesuny přesunout a do
konce měsíce dát dohromady ten nákupní
seznam. Protože hardware na základě toho,
jak dopadlo to testování.
Takže takhle přímo.
Okolo.
Pavlučko prosím tady milník hele já mám
tu,
to znamená ty lžičce jsou teda hotové a
typy běží a byl tam byl tam vlastně je to
dnešek, tak evidentně to asi ne.
Jack.
Stop.
Takový web pizzarový.
Mě to nezáleží na mně,
je to na vítkovi tak jako dala bych tam
tu středu a nebo 2000.
No ať mám nějakej buffr ještě.
Tak víceméně do zmapovali situaci,
tam jsme se zatím domluvili,
Jenom.
no že nebudou v pořících.
Byli jsme si probrat jenom to,
jestli to nějakým způsobem otestujeme
nějakým způsobem.
Už jsme se bavili, že?
Double.
Dokončíme schválení, to je.
Vedle.
Hodnotný proud je hotový.
Podřízení.
Kdyby.
To bylo dneska tak to vlastně asi do
třicátýho 4. Nebo?
A dej tam konec měsíce,
pojď tam dáme vítkovi prostor.
A jak jsem říkala?
Protože dokončeny,
tak nás jako v ničem neblokuje.
Martinovi příští týden nikam nejedete.
Jo 1 jedete do toho hosina?
Martine.
Tak jo a to bude 30.
Ty vogo.
Já v to doufám já v to doufám.
Pluskoviček na tom ten víkend teďka s
tímdle ho tam jestli do toho už hrábnu,
nebo vůbec nehrábnu.
Hele psal mi že ne že řeší nějaký rodinný
problémy,
takže že že se na to buď koukne zítra
nebo příští týden,
tak proto jako tam nechci dávat nějakej
ná krk mu termín,
tak bych tam dala ten konec měsíce,
jestli je to jako za tebe reálný.
Tam je to jako reálný je,
ale musí se to udělat pondělí úterý no.
Pokud pojedou testovat na depo, tak.
No tak tam dejme měsíce a to už snad bude
poslední posun.
Ovšem 2 2 pokusy 1 a druhej pak už nejde.
Já říkám tam,
bylo tam byl stěžejní layout chráště a na
To už neumí.
základě něho vznikly nějaký potřeby
přesunu a užitce a zdibi.
To už je prostě jenom o nějakým doladění
s provozem.
Tam už to jako úplně není nějak kritický,
že je to, že bude layout později,
takže na něčem jako bude blokovat abysme
případně nemohli provést ten stres test,
jak jsme se o tom bavili s vítkem.
Spíš tam by nám řekl.
Nicpaně.
Jako celkově ten projekt má být hotový do
srpna.
Tak říkám, nemyslím si, že tam je něco,
co nás jako blokuje v tom,
Problém?
Já.
když budeme mít tenhle outovi později.
Tady.
Já se já se omlouvám ale my jsme si
dohodli, že to je 15 bábí.
Tak já nevím kdo.
Patnáctýho 5 jsme chtěli dělat nějakým
způsobem ten stres test.
Dobře pojďme pracovat.
Abysme zjistili,
jestli jako jsme v pohodě,
jestli máme dělat ještě nějaký další
kroky, abysme stihli tu příjmovou sezónu,
Tak pojďme to dát klika.
která začíná 1 8.
Protože.
Je mravenej.
Příjem a sezónu má bejt 31 úseky.
Dobře dobře 1. 8. začíná přímá.
Sezóna.
Přidat nebo 7 minut?
Otázka,
jak já si ještě pořád nejsem s tím
ztrastest tak jistej domlouvali jsme se s
Tomášem, že si řekneme,
co vlastně na tom chceme měřit.
Z toho očekáváme za výstup,
takže se jako má bejt stres test nemá
bejt já teďka jako neumím říct,
protože na expedici ty stres testy děláme
Z.
jako s ohledem na technologii.
U příjmů by to bylo i jako je to spíš vo
organizaci práce.
Jestli to dobře,
jako jestli to dobře vnímám.
Jo,
jako když to řeknu třeba na příkladu
Jo.
určit, tak tam třeba teďka jako.
Už bys to dělal na.
Aktuální poštovou adle stejné ale to je
rychlej se tam také jako musíme,
když děláme ten 100 na experiment,
taky musíme jako zvýšit počet lidí.
Jo ale jako že tím že tam nejsou ty
technologie, tak vlastně.
Ten výkon se přímo.
Jako.
Měl být, o kolik to dělá lidi.
No je to podle mě jako organizace práce
jako zvládnu zorganizovat tak,
že tam jako vyložej ten objem zvládne
nebo zpracovat, nikde se jim tam jako.
Kupí jako 2. Věc je, jako že my si můžeme.
Jako zkresleně v uvozovkách,
jako byli jsme schopni to přijmout,
ale my musíme asi jako řešit,
že to bude to stihli.
Prudce naskladní.
Jako když.
To znamená.
Vandalové.
Otázka je,
jestli to tak platí standardní že jo.
Jo, to jsou ty podmínky,
které si musíme jako definovat,
jestli to vůbec měřit.
K tomu, já jsem teda jako 1,
37 ve všech skladech třídy jsou redy pod
novýho nějakýho?
Ano to platí.
Jo až dnes srpnu ale.
Co to co já tady jako slyším tím je to,
že chrášt to nech potřebu dělat, upravit.
To je připravený.
Lucka jere to přidat na to 1 pátýho začít
dělat ty úpravy a ulice nepotřebujou
úpravy, bude to o změně kingatu.
Ano.
Takže v zásadě jako tam to bude o tom
spíš jako víc,
jako bejt v úzkým kontaktu s tím mírou
obaletem a.
Jo ale to.
Jo.
Ale.
S tím ty data a tam to tam to funguje,
jako když už se to prověřovalo.
Oni prostě jako tohle dělají jako
každoročně. Minulý rok jsme to dělali,
že si ten booking jako řídí jako sami
podle toho, co jako se na ně valí.
Takže to jako není o tom,
že já teďka řeknu,
otevřeme booking OX hodin deal.
A mít.
To jako dělají v sezóně,
když to potřebuji, dokud to není,
jako že tam zavedeme něco nového a je to
právě o tom řízení toho toho výkonu.
Takže jinými slovy jako ty.
Funguje jako oni tvrdí, nebo takhle.
Já jsem jako.
Řekl myšlenku, že jako chápu, že krášenek,
kde jsme dělali nějaké úpravy,
tak tam dává smysl to otestovat,
protože jsme prostě ten proces změnil
málo.
Těch skladeb, kde dojdeme k tomu závěru,
což teda nedošlo.
Víceméně v těch užžicích nevím,
jestli IV těch týdnech že jako změny
dělat nechceme, protože provoz říká s tím,
jak se tam změnila směnnost,
tak jsou schopni toho výkonu dosáhnout
tak, jako je na nás jako říct si OK.
Potřebujem teda jako testovat,
když jsme tam asi nic nezměnili a pak
říkám, že to je v pohodě.
Jo že jako jestli tam je ten ten
investovat?
Bez regie a peníze do.
Toho ale tam nová situace teď čelíme.
Program.
Programu.
Klid.
Pojďme dál. Lucko, prosím tě,
já tady vyčíslení nákladů na opravu těch
plot je 20. Čtvrtýho s tím, že toho bude.
Až třicátýho dubna bude teda ten příběh?
Tak jo, to se taky posouvá, nebo to platí?
To je pátek, teďka toto.
Tohle to se týká chrášťan to řeším s
Lukášem to platí.
Dobře, tak jo, musel jsem se zeptat.
Tím pádem asi za příjem.
Hele a já ještě počkej zpátky ty volníky,
vyhodnocení testování RS canderu ty jsi
říkala, přijdeme.
No v pátek začnu testovat,
takže za tejden to stihneme mít
vyhodnocený.
No, původně jsem počítala,
že tam budeme mít minimálně o tejden dýl,
uvidíme, jak to testování půjde. Je možný,
že to budem muset trošku posunout od
tejden,
ale zatím to bych to tam nechala na toho.
Teď to rovnou posuňme rovnou posuňme jo,
jestli to jako víme, jestli víme,
že to teďka nestihneme tak to rovnou jako
pojďme dát termín, kterej stíháme,
ať tady každej tejden, nebo co máme.
Ho někdy?
Takže luccoka?
Tak tam dej desátýho.
A to znamená i vytvoření nákupního
seznamu nový hardware jo.
Ano ano.
60.
To s tím souvisí taky.
OK.
Tak dobrý.
OK.
Tím pádem takhle.
Tak jo.
Jednatřicátýho července 20:20 6 $ jo
docela hned ty kapacity těch palet.
Tak vratné palety.
Děkujeme lockované palety to patří nebo
Filip jo, vidíš to jo vítej promiň.
Já jsem tady.
Pardon, děkuji, děkuji.
Připoj jsem se později,
ale jsem tady status, prosím tě, nemáme.
Je to z toho důvodu,
že se stala vlastně jenom 1 zásadní věc.
Tak jsem kvůli tomu nechtěl psát status.
Teď jsme v situaci,
kdy potřebujeme dokončit stavební
přípravu datových kabeláží.
Nějak jsem došťouchal Martina čeka,
aby se to dodělalo a dneska jsem dneska,
pardon, včera jsem schválil.
Lils.
Tu invetu připravu, takže teďka čekáme,
až se ty data dotáhnou. Jak má data,
budou mít na místě dotažené,
tak my jsme připraveni na instalaci brány
a na spuštění toho testovacího provozu.
To je vlastně jenom takový jako rychlej
rekup nic.
Jinak zásadního se vlastně nestalo jediný,
co tedy tak musím v tuto chvíli tedy říci,
že ten status je etris.
Nejsme ještě oftrack,
ale byli bychom attrysk.
Jelikož nejsem teďka, ještě si jako jistý,
kdy bude ten termín tý dostavby?
A nejsem přesvědčenej tedy,
že bohužel stihneme ten příští týden
konec toho dubna,
kdybychom ten provoz chtěli ozkoušet.
Pokud by ty datový přípravy byly do konce
tohoto týdne, je hotový, tak si myslím,
že to asi ještě s ondřejma ušima.
Stihneme tam s tím a rychle dodat,
ale spíš si to nemyslím.
Tudíž dneska říkám et risk a to riziko
tedy je,
že příští týden bych bohužel nahlásil,
že budeme of track.
Pokud by tato situace nastala na to
dodání nainstalování, tak místo 4 5.
Se si myslím, že ten termín bude 15.
Takže to teďka avizuji,
že takovéhle riziko existuje?
Příští týden bych to případně potvrdil či
vyvrátil. Zde jsme to stihli.
To už je heavy etris OK.
Ano to je to je hewattryska no.
Hele čtvrtýho 5 jsme se bavili,
že jo minulý týden necháme to tam zatím
teda nebudeme to měnit a příští tejden si
řekneme, kde jsme.
Jo jo jo teďka říkám,
že to je atrisk ještě jako nějaká malá,
ta malá vesmítková lidi si myslím,
že tam je,
protože naše flexibilita dodělání těch
antén je jako rychlá.
To tam kluci dodělají hned jenom čekají
až to bude aintech to je schopný dodat v
rámci dnů,
ale nejsem si teďka jako jistý nebo
neznám ten termín dokončení té datové
sítě, takže nedokážu říct, proto říkám,
je to risk.
Toť asi koše.
Uvidíme.
1.
Co.
K tomu právníková síť jo.
Jinak.
Jo.
Měl by tam být.
Který vůbec?
Tady jsou ty světa tady ano.
Tak.
Takhle.
Tak.
To se nestalo.
Jo.
Já já ještě vidím, že to stále nenačítá.
Jo.
Už to vidíme.
Jo.
Asi tam je nějaká akce.
Tak.
Jo dobrý dobrý, tak tam chce do.
Počkat to není to co jsem.
Ty Tomáš posunutý vašku nebo tohle je to
poslední, co ty vidíš?
15. 4.
Ta s tím ne, to je špatně.
Aha, pardon to je.
Vidím tady.
To je špatně, ne, já jsem to,
já jsem tam psal alenovi.
Dobře o dobře, já se omlouvám,
já se omlouvám,
jestli jsem to neodklikl jo,
tak moje chyba,
ale ale měl tam být tak minimálně
nervopix no, doufám, že se propsal.
Zkusím takhle ještě 1:15 tady 15.
Dubna tady.
Jo tak to se omlouvám, já jsem.
Já jsem trošku jako lítal dneska v kanclu
tak myslím,
že jsem to jako odklikával dobře,
tak já to jenom sesumi do teda rychle
jenom z hlavy.
My teďka to pokračujeme,
pokračujeme dle plánu.
Stavební příprava běží.
Máme zatím potvrzeno i od Aleše teda,
že podle plánu ta ta úprava těch plošin
má zítra být hotová,
což byl náš teda původní původní termín.
Takže SSHZ toho,
co bylo plánovaný dle dle plánů.
Zároveň i no tak teďka teda dávat do kupy
nějakou tu investuru materiálům máme teda
nějakej jako obecnej feedback,
že trošku tam maj víc hledání,
než jsme čekali, ale asi to není nic,
co mě úplně zarazilo. Myslím,
že tam za mě.
Ta.
A dohoda nebyla perfektně,
ale maržujeme si to.
Takže ta ta stavební příprava do tepla
dle očekávání a plánu bitvy a příští
týden měli kluci zahájit nějakou tu 1
montáž a stavbu. Ty dopravníkový sítě.
Měli bychom začínat,
tedy na plošině na levé lodi,
teda na 4 na 4 FA odtamtud teda budeme
táhnout ten nový jižní sjezd.
Co bych tady jenom zmínil,
ale nechci to tady řešit asi do té velké
jako podrobnosti.
My jsme s Lukášem si bohužel v rámci
posledních rizik trošku potvrdili naše
obavy ohledně kapacit těch soutrů,
abych tady nebyl nějakou velkou omáčku.
Měli jsme tam nějaký předpoklad,
který se nestal, nebo který jako dneska.
Aktuálně se na tom skladě neděje,
to nám ovlivňuje ty kapacity těch sortrů,
které jsme původně počítali a mysleli si,
že.
Potečou v jiných číslech.
Mi na tady to konto máme teda připravený,
řekněme nějaký akční plán,
jak to chceme řešit nějak v tom našem
projektu si budeme přidávat ve spolupráci
pepi kinera a Michala sažina tady ty 2
nové členy a budeme s nima řešit nasazení
těch změn nebo úpravy těch procesů hlavně
v rámci třízení ropase a intraluxu tak
abychom se dostali.
Na ty čísla,
které jsme v těch původních úvahách měli
nebo na základě těch.
Předtuch, které jsme s Lukášem měli,
takže tady jenom nějaká poměrně zásadní.
Bych řekl jakoby změna.
Co to pro nás s Lukášem znamená?
Je my ten,
my tady ty úpravy dělat nebudeme pouze s
jako Michala a pepu k sobě do toho
projektu vezmeme,
aby jsme řekněme nějakým způsobem vedli a
abysme si tu situaci managovali nás se ty
témata stejně jako párujou nebo na sebe
navazujou, tak to není od věci,
abychom to spolu řešili a tu práci budu
vykonávat.
Oni mi s Lukášem řekněme tam budeme mít
jenom ten projektovej supervizing.
Jedinej impact tady to v tuto chvíli pro
nás s Lukášem má.
Je to, že my teďka těch příštích.
Říkám ti,
ze začátku asi do příštího měsíce
nebudeme a nebudeme jako se výrazně.
Orientovat nebo výrazně přepočítávat ty
kapacity toho na té síť toho Bangladéše.
Ten bangladéš teďka dáváme řekněme na 2
kolej.
Budeme se primárně soustředit na tu práci
úprav těch třídění, tak,
jak potřebujeme pro tu dopravníkovou síť.
AK tomu bangare, že se vrátíme později,
zatím to jako riziko nevnímám,
protože my stejně víme,
že do léta kino té kapacity na té
bangladéš nemá.
Takže kdybysme něco připravili,
tak to z té super řešit nebudeme.
Je to jenom nějaká jako okolnost,
kterou zmiňuju,
že se díky tomu jakoby děje jo.
T.
OK.
Pan vede dvacátýho dubna to platí v té
pátek. Potvrdit si ty potřeby to platí.
To.
Ne, ne, ne, ne,
tohle tohle tohle za mě tohle za mě
neplatí.
Tady ten posun bude teďka drastickej a
řekněme, že ten ten datum bude. 22. 5.
OK.
Jenom té 27 4 platí nebo ne to platí.
Ano ano to stále platí.
A.
19. 6. i přes ten drastický postup.
Ano jo to stále platí jo.
Tak jo.
Dobře já nevím takhle.
Když ti jestli vlastně, kdyby to slyšel,
tak tam potom se vypadne náš ten status.
Jo, on si někdo propíše potom,
že jo buďme.
Jo jo ano ano omlouvám se omlouvám se.
Buďme.
To bylo.
Ano to?
To stálo odvod, jak to k tomu můžu říct?
Je to, že teďka to já předávám,
alešovi požadavky na stavební přípravu a
to je vlastně všechno, co se tam stalo.
Tady až nejbližší a až tady někde v
květnu.
Jako jo takže OK.
Tak.
No a bobc.
Tak robopic.
Roboti.
Takže jsme nějaký kolize v rámci autoserů,
že teda meruňka nedosáhneme tak?
Jo,
to jsou nějaké nějaké nějaké design
Jo drobnosti.
designové dopady? Jenom to asi teďka,
tak co se týče robopiku zase jenom v
Tedy.
krátkosti jdeme.
Teda pokračujeme ontrack v tom,
co jsme si říkali minulej týden,
tudíž tento týden vlastně se primárně
soustředíme na tu poslední vlnu těch.
Pak fixování a nějakých těch nedostatků
nebo ladění, co člověk potřebuje.
Dělat,
my jsme to konto právě odděláme naší
straně to samý tady bych řekl,
to je hodně ve spolupráci nebo hodně na
straně Martina kiše,
kterej nám udělal tu 1 analýzu všech těch
různejch tasků a operací,
který se dějou mezi ramenem AKAAIT našli,
jsou tam už ňáké discipence 1 bych i že
už se rovnou vyřešila na straně Pavel
růžičky. To bylo situace,
kdy jsme hlásili falešný shortpicky,
takže za tohle jako velkej díky za
rychlou reakci.
A teď tady ten tejden řekněme obecně
pracujeme dál.
Já už já už jsem všechny ty case jako
nerozopis nerozepisoval. Je to to stejné,
co bylo v těch předchozích tázcích?
Hm.
Ohledně toho plánování stále jdeme tím
směrem, co jsme si,
co jsem indikova minulej týden to znamená
příští týden je taková ta velká alfa
omega od pondělí do středy,
tedy budeme pouštět obě stanice na celých
Cokoliv.
8 hodin. Každý den to znamená pondělí,
úterý i středu,
abychom začali nabírat nějaký jako
poznatky.
Jak opravdu tady ty stanice tedy běží po
všech těch updatech s tím,
že čtvrtek zakončíme den d finálním s
testováním AZ tohoto dne my budeme se
sertem dělat detailní kalkulaci těch
výsledků porovnávat SKPIA.
Pak se teda uděláme nějaké to finální
sezení a řekneme si, přebíráme,
nepřebíráme na tadyto konto jsem
domluvený s Honzou linharttem,
že se tam za náma zastaví také jak v
pondělí, tak ve čtvrtek.
Budeme to řekněme sledovat opravdu na
místě.
A podle tohodle posoudíme vlastně jako
úspěšnost toho projektu a finální
převzetí. Pokud všechno dopadne dle pánu,
tak 4,
5 řekněme začínáme ten oficiální golive a
předávání do toho provozu.
My počítáme, že se to povede,
když máme tady kvalitu roboku. 80.
Procent.
Ano já s tím počítám,
protože tady ty výsledky jsou ovlivněny
tím, že děláme to buckfixování.
Jak začneme toho robota opravdu
utelizovat,
tak ono se to nebudeme na něj neustále
šahat.
Tak ty čísla se akorát pídně zvednou.
Jo mám.
Není to jako že by teď cucal vzduch mám
ten mám to podložený tím,
že když si vytáhneme datově ty cyklusy.
Těch času,
kdy opravdu nesaháme na toho robota,
tak mi jako jsme schopný už dneska těch 5
jako téměř dosáhnout.
Dobře,
když teda půjdu ještě 1 sem pro
knihovníka, tak.
Hm.
Tady to všechno sedí.
Jo dubna to sedí jo?
Jo toho toho třicátýho.
Ten čtvrtek je ten den d kdy se tady to
šilhu potvrdíme a na základě toho,
že to uspěje tak čtvrtýho 5,
máme ten oficiální golive jo.
Pondělí čtvrtek jo.
Jenom tyhle 2 dny jde o pondělí a čtvrtek.
Pondělí až čtvrtek.
Černý 4 dny v kuse a 8 hodin od 8 do 16
kámo.
Jo jo jedeme.
Přesně tak přesně tak.
Zvědavej, jak se to bude povídat.
To já taky.
No tak jo.
Tak.
1. Walter.
P.
Dík jo, díky moc.
Mie co se to povede jo jo.
Hele dík díky, díky moc, díky moc.
Budem se snažit.
No jo.
Máš, nemáte nějaké otázky? Já se omlouvám,
protože já potřebuji na další schůzku,
Třeba přihlásit.
tak jenom, jestli to je všechno,
tak já uteču.
Dobře.
Na tebe všechno filipe, děkuje děkujeme.
Jo dobrý super tak jo hele díky ahoj.
A myslím si,
že asi obec máme všechno linku až k
nějakým závěrem.
Máme přednost.
Závěrem není jako dostáváme se k zpoždění.
Přijde,
Nyní.
že ten duben byl takovej pro nás teďka
kritický.
Zároveň jsem z toho trošku nervózní, no?
Co nebo?
To mi pomohlo.
Je potřeba se jako podívat dopředu,
kam kam to spěje,
jestli už někde jako nevidíme.
Jestli už někdy nevím,
jak dar hele a případně případně s tím
jako občas přijít a říct si, říct si,
co ještě?
Můžeme upravit no.
Rizika opravdu jako tím,
že tady z Vašek je?
Eviduje poměrně důkladně,
takže řídíme jako dostatečně s předstihem.
AA nenecháme to vyvolat jo.
Tak jo prosím všichni si já myslím že.
Zaměřte na to,
jestli s těma rizikama nebo s těma
posunama těch milníků,
jestli tam jako nevzniká nějaký jako
zásadní riziko, který nás.
Který nás může jako potopit, no.
Jako tohle já tady jenom příští týdny
schůzce nebudu.
Ale možná mě napadá udělat jako nějakou
rizikovou hygienu výměnu rizik jako
1.
zkusit to jako dostavit se podívat se už
jako dát. Pokud věnovat češtinu,
rizikový problém nebo nějakým prosbám
jako nějaký čas jít si,
na tohle tohle problém?
Jakoby z tohodlenctoho úhlu pohledu víc
než jenom tohleto by tohle vidět.
Je to ještě popsat nebo vyšťourat ty,
který dneska třeba si myslíme, že jsou,
nebo že nejsou,
nebo něco nějak jako ještě víc?
Jako u kopidla.
Czech to jako z podle pohledu,
ať si jste naprosto jistí, že víme.
Je to pojmenovaný,
mám nenakopené nám to či nám to na
kopenia.
Jo můžete příští tejden jako místo
statusu udělat na workshop jo.
Ale já to ještě popřemejšlim a případně
bych mohl bejt ten koncept,
že bychom si vzali téma po tématu a řekli
bychom si nějaký grémiu nějaký ty facarty
a problémy,
abychom tady pojmenovaný a případně ještě
povedlo nějak reagovat.
Což ve finále je to, co třeba.
Jinak bych podle mě velmi rád ještě.
Já popřemýšlím napíšu zprávu do chatu.
Ale spíš jakože máme tady krásně
evidovaný ty posuny, ty milníky,
tak ať s nimi jako pracujeme,
ať to není jenom evidovaný,
ale s nima opravdu pracujeme, protože.
Dneska jsme tady jako viděli, posouváme,
posouváme o týden, posouváme o tejden,
posouváme o tejden.
Začínáme se dostávat toho vztahu.
Kdybysme byli,
loni jsme jako posouvali o týden,
tak možná fakt bude jako dobrý se
zastavit příští tejden,
nedělat jako standardní status,
kterej tady jako vidíme každej tejden,
ale zastavit se a udělat si takovouhle
jako analýzu analýzu těch rizik.
To by bylo fajn no že potom toho 6 máme
ten měsíční obdivu, tak tam zase.
Tohle jsem zený voní silný já.
Jenom si to.
Jako zkus musím táhnout,
musíme vytáhnout to,
co jsou ty akční kroky pro to,
aby se to změnilo, je to jako tak.
Dobrou noc za touhle co jinýho.
Jsem chápu.
Zase.
Ok tak jo.
Dobroš.
Máme odprezentování,
děkujeme všem za práci a pak začneme dál,
Děkujeme.
přijme palce.
Díky čau ahoj.
Taky díky ahoj.
Ahoj.